hello good afternoon I hope nobody's
hungry okay so my first question is who
has Twitter account raise your hands and
the next question is who writes tweet
like about once a week or more often our
subject is about sentiment analyzing of
tweets in Polish language using a deep
learning
my name is Yana Pico
I work as a data scientist at enigma
cutter in my job I working with data
from really different sources like
chemistry radars photos but personally I
really like analyzing data so and
started stick strong social media
especially Twitter here is agenda first
thing I would like to talk about
and that is how to get takeout for
research then how to make text as input
to a network third point is about
labeling the data and at the end I will
talk about the bottle which I use so we
will go through the whole process so
first question how to pin the data we
can get a dark of dark in
so for tweets in the English language
from example from camel in CS
performance for our tweets in Polish
language it's not so easy so don't
solutions first one we can use Twitter
API with Python Twitter package if we
want to use Twitter API and we need
Twitter account and it's easy to just do
it and - with which give us an
opportunity to search - it in specific
language so it not only polish but
example in Spain Norwegian as
but here there is a one problem a big
problem because you have a time limit
per one request
so at once we can just take from Twitter
only about 6,000 tweets so for my
research it wasn't enough so I go second
options the second option is another
package which is called a get of tweets
free because it's part of the for Python
free and it's it has an implementation
but it has different problem because it
was impossible to search tweets by the
language but we can research tweets by
there for example CDs and I searched
tweets from the biggest cities what like
war so cracker
but but I take this tweets and I look
into the tweets were in different
language but only in college so it comes
to that point about data processing
first week the first thing we must be
sure that all text we have our to the
same language so there is a package
called Lonnie Tech which detects the
language of that we'd so I searched and
checked everything polished and justice
only works and which I was interested in
and another problem is that that tweets
are not only text but emojis links to
their webpages usernames and things like
dogs
other pigs so we must remove it and I
think that simply observing is using
records formulas and the last week I
think the exist was to convert text to
the release of the single watch still is
the question if the pure text can be
imposed to delete never our network if
not exactly so we have it creates what
anti thinks so
language we have in America every
presentation and we have factors about
which length is immense
the most popular option it's 100 hundred
but to train on your all the work to
make model it's not so easy with large
data
Oh
purpose so the time of processing is
data is huge and the training
my work is much longer so I decided to
use retrain to back that work for Polish
language polish Science Academy which I
chose which was trained on national
corpus and some of the tweets just has
because your presentation of well the
motor area can be opened and then using
cancel that so it's easy to here is an
example of some tweets in Polish these
after numbers which are the
representation of for every word is
indexed find the index can find that
it's worth embedding in words come back
an example and you can see
- that has different to them and these
numbers also have different like so
there's another problem but it is a dose
of it are we looking for the text which
has the longest which is the longest and
then we learn from all the next we have
to the size of the longest and that's a
lumen number outside the range of the
least of the land of list of all words
in specific language in Polish it's not
very far
two hundred
and I'm here we have all these of the
same size so we can concatenate it to
the least to the right but okay we have
like time which is ready to put it in
neural network but we don't have diapers
it would be hard to do
or just doing five people so I was very
interesting - it's called desk effective
for at least this list of words exist
not only for Polish language but also
for the Spanish French it is created by
the researchers and they ask
group of mini speaker of the specific
language about the Phoenix what they
have about every word the lease has only
two thousand words but it describes
final five emotions like happiness anger
sadness in task and fear not only just
if the word is positive negative or
neutral which is the most popular option
it has our options it's marketing it
describes a mother this list has
numerical representation of emotion for
every list of words all the words are in
the basic grammar form so for people who
post written knowledge I would like to
say that pollute grammar is very rich
and we
very very you have many grammar forms of
words but for this problem you can
convert words to the it's basic grammar
form there is a package called Marcos
it has described every word and polish
the pace drummer for so it just do it
and change every word to the basic as I
said before this list has only two
thousand words
polish is that number of words is more
than two thousand I look for the
synonyms and all the synonyms get I
described with the same vector which has
word beautiful and backing to the tweets
for every word I look if it has vector
of motion representation and then for
hole is for hole tweet I calculate
emotional presentation which was just a
mean of values of whole vectors for the
sentence here is example I not say that
about one thing well I trash how the
threshold that the values because they
are in the range from 1 to 5 so I told
them about the mean of all values and
here are example in Polish well there is
a
tweet and under it's a vector it's a
vector representation first numbers is
about if a text has happiness emotion
inside second is anger third is sadness
fourth is fear and the last one is
disgust
and you can see that the fourth example
has only zeros which means that the text
is neutral and now we can move I think
today
the part which give us fun which is
training the neural network to classify
emotion in our tweets in my research I
train my model on about 400,000 tweets I
think it's a lot and the test data set
was about 100 tweets here is a model
this is output from the tensorflow first
layer is embedding layer which had the
weights from the word too vague and I
choose option where word embedding
vectors has length 300 element the
second layer is lsdm layer with 100 lsdm
cells and the last layer is dense layer
which has three neurons because I look
for free emotions
and there is no information but the
activation activation function was Sigma
Adele because I want to have multi-label
classifier as you may see on previous as
here because we have not only just one
emotion in text but we have for example
3 or 0 and it was my model it has so you
can see it has so much parameters and
the result was I think it was good it
was about 80% on a train data set it was
82% and on that test data set was 79 I
think it's good ok so now we have time
for questions and thank you for your
attention
yeah it's a one-person
unfortunately not but we heard today
that there is a bird language model and
I think in the future maybe I will use
it but if someone is a Twitter user
maybe you know that this information
about the bird language model not only
for English was about three days ago on
a Google account any other questions
about
yes
not exactly maybe I will come back maybe
- yes but well maybe I move here so if
every word I look to the list if the
word is on a list and then I checked if
least I check the representation and I
find for every word the vector that
describes emotions and then I calculate
the mean of all these vectors
can you repeat the question
just label more than one the dust tool
labor the text that well
it's working okay okay and then under
those data set which was created by Road
based methods you trained the deep
neural network yes because I the
training set for network was created by
YouTube based methods yeah by those
dictionary of words okay and have you
maybe checked
what's the accuracy of this method the
rule based method like if the amount
words got some negations okay you mean
checking the mad method of labeling yes
yes here is an example and I look into
the of course to the labels and it's not
often well the representation of the
emotion but for Polish language
I really haven't found something better
of course you can make a risk like
research to ask as many people as
possible to label whole phrases for
example which will be much better but
first thing is it's an expensive and
well it's time-consuming it's not part
of the data scientist job
about the labeling there is a package
snorkel I don't know if you heard about
it this is a package exactly for
labeling datasets so if you have a data
set which with many cases but very few
of them is labeled then like it has an
algorithm able to learn the labeling and
label rest of the data so I'm not sure
if it's working with text data but like
maybe it's something for experimenting
okay any other questions
thank you very much five minutes for
technical break now thank you
[Applause]